hey guys Pete here just a quick video
today since there were some new photos
from season seven and this does contain
spoilers if you don't want to see
anything from season seven in advance so
the first and most impressive photo is
definitely the picture of Dragoon with
Daenerys on back in battle we can see
the scale here and drogon is absolutely
huge at this point even if you're not a
fan of Danny's story or the Dragons in
general this is pretty impressive you
have to admit not really sure I'm sure
some people will be upset but the fact
that he's grown so fast but we are
nearing the end of the series and and
I'm just looking at the photo as I'm
talking about it and it is damn
impressive I mean imagine if Danny
showed up on your doorstep like that the
next photo is of Jon Snow
he's on horseback he's got his
cold-weather gear on and he looks to be
in Winterfell and the inside there I'm
sure that fans of Jon Snow or Kit
Harington it will be really excited
about this photo it doesn't really tell
us much though we know Jon's in the
north we know he's king in the north
and we know that he will probably ride
horses at some time during the season so
it's a cool pick but nothing new to see
there
this is Arya on horseback and this is
very similar to other images we've seen
but I gotta ask have we become so jaded
that we don't even care that Arya was
literally doing montage fight scenes and
action teams and everything else in
Bravo
last season I mean this is not new
information but it's still pretty damn
exciting and I think we should all just
be fans at this man it's um if you
haven't followed spoilers or if you have
I mean there's a lot of stuff that's
tied into this photo and this is good
for the Starks this is good for
everything and I you can give me plenty
of pictures of Arya on horseback and I
will still probably get excited get
another shot of Littlefinger and Sansa
that looks like it was taken at the same
time of the other one that they released
in the original dump of photos
fifteen photos awhile ago now this one's
a little less inspiring than the Aria
one for me just because Santa has been
with Littlefinger for some time of
course it's a little bit more exciting
because she's at Winterfell but we
already saw pretty much this exact same
photo and we already know what's going
to transpire for the most part in that
relationship we also got some behind the
scenes type photos which are always a
little bit interesting to see first one
we see tormund Giantsbane also looks to
be at Winterfell you can see the area in
the background where they photographs on
Sun little finger in the last photo we
knew tormund was coming back we knew
where he was at so not a lot to talk
about here except for hey man Foreman's
a cool character always has been but
this gives us no new information beyond
what we've already seen another behind
the scenes photo is of Gwendoline
Christie who plays Brienne she's kind of
cheating they're smiling it's a pretty
cool photo I think it's a cool character
who's not usually smiling ever so it's
nice to see the actor off the set just
enjoying the process kind of makes you
jealous a little bit or at least I
should say it makes me jealous a little
bit I mean that's a pretty good job
being Brienne of Tarth I would think and
she does a great job I should mention as
well so haven't heard a lot of people
talk about this one but I did enjoy
seeing it and Gwendolyn does have a
great smile another behind the scenes
one is the photo of Cersei sitting on
the Iron Throne with Jaime at her side
we saw the exact close-up still of this
with you know we could see widows wail
there on his hip and all that and your
the other 15 photos that came out so
this one is perhaps the most boring of
all which is trying to crazy when you
think about it but I love Cersei
I don't really dig the way that their
relationships going in the show compared
to the books or whatever but I can
usually get pretty hyped up especially
seeing Cersei on the throne and since
I've seen this already it's really not
too exciting at all kind of neat from a
technical standpoint though I mean I
don't know that I've ever seen the Iron
Throne from that angle and the way the
set is built there so yeah maybe some
people will dig it for that so HBO put
these photos out it's kind of a
disappointment considering that
everyone's been waiting for a trailer at
this point Entertainment Weekly has
released them so I guess they have the
rights therefore there's all those giant
entertainment weekly' water marks on the
bottom I was looking at Twitter this
morning and I saw that there is maybe
some static about other sites using the
photos or something like that but I'll
put a link to the Entertainment Weekly
article in the comments if you want to
look at them closer tell me what you
think I mean Daenerys looks pretty much
like an ant on drove ons back so he's
like blaring the black dreadscythe now
almost it would be cool what makes me
think about is what are the other
dragons look like right now I mean that
is not something I was expecting for him
to be so big at this point so are the
other two keeping up I mean I'm sure
he's the biggest but are they pretty
large too or are they a little bit
slower to develop
let me know what you guys think about
these photos are you dying for trailers
so you're just sort of mad on these if
you haven't seen many photos of anything
from the season make sure you check out
my season sever and spoilers playlist
we've been putting them all out as soon
as we got them since the very beginning
of filming and there's a ton of great
photos in there if you want to see might
explain why some people just don't care
that much about these ones thanks for
watching I will talk to you soon